of course if you just take the Knight
you lose your queen but simply check
oops this king is on the board and then
take the Knight on the next move so
after Knight to A6 where can the queen
go again if Queen to d8 another
variation then the move Queen D6 check
for starters you can do anything you
want about this check and then all of a
sudden oh sorry wrong
one all of a sudden uh the move Knight
to
C5 attacking the Knight and again
problems defending that Knight black was
actually winning with Knight A6 Knight
A6 was winning the Knight cold but he
missed that move after Queen to C7 he
would have gotten a severe Advantage
instead he quickly went for a trade of
Queens this ending though yes I'm really
fascinated by the computer is saying
that it's even or slightly better for
black this Knight is again in trouble he
has to trade queens now he has no choice
and after this move B takes C6 looking
to turn these pawns into monsters yes
this position looks looks
really difficult to assess the computer
is saying even but we probably have to
make a bunch of moves before we can
decide if this G Pawn is not powerful or
these two pawns versus these guys over
here of course this Pawn is hanging let
me just make one move Knight to E5 to
guard the pawn and now C5 and how do you
defend this as white let's just make a
move G4 for example and wow the computer
is giving that natural move Knight takes
Knight takes and
C4 whoa the players are going to have
their hands full trying to calculate
these kinds of positions very difficult
to assess what's actually going on right
now in this game and both sides now
under 13 minutes 1240 1238 and Ticking
for gev 1037 and Ticking
for for uh Ramirez actually only Ramirez
is on move right now so Queen takes C6
check has been played he realized it was
his only move and best is to take with
the pawn but he's taking with the King
he is captured with the King let's see
if that makes a difference here King
takes on C6 apparently gives white a
slight Edge but now it's saying the
position is essentially even but tricky
lines again the D Pawn is hanging if
Knight to E5 check King to D6 and this
is what Ramirez is looking at is he
winning after this line Knight to C4
check is the only move because the pawn
is hanging he has to do something about
that and what's happening in this
endgame y this one looks crazy after
D3 help me out here this is wild stuff
oh wild for sure it's so infuriating and
the variations that you've just shown
where black for a moment there had three
connected pass pawns all of them
dangerous uh going on to become a queen
and the computer goes 0000 and you say
sitting there saying what these
extraordinarily unbalanced decisions are
uh positions are very hard for humans to
properly evaluate and I would just say
that if I were white I'd be very very
fearful that I would be
losing that's right we've got some
comments on that actually John Kate he
tweeted into our hash usest Champs with
computers so Advanced now I think it's
unfair to hold the players to computer
standards yeah we totally agree with you
or I I certainly agree with that um
sometimes when you're watching at home
and you got your engine on you might
think that it's more incredible that a
player blunder than it actually is
because you don't let yourself go
through that process of how difficult it
is to find only move if you're using um
an engine so I would agree that we do
not hold computers to um humans to
computer standards we do not do that at
all please the computers are beast they
see millions and millions of moves a
second uh tactics they're just so far
Advanced ahead of the rest of us it
doesn't make any sense to do that but
they do illuminate the play for us to
make us see exactly what is actually
going on in the position so there are
useful tools but please mistakes are
what humans do and uh it's only natural
so we are able to compare how the fine
play of the computer would stack up
against human moves and when the humans
find Brilliant ideas you just got to
think wow total genius
that's right and we've also got John B
bartholomeu again and I am um who's also
a very well-known chess coach he says
that
Alejandro now has bot vinic variation
like counterplay with his Queen Pawn
Queens side pawns and he agrees with uh
with us that this has been a wild game
from the get-go thank you guys for
contributing we love to hear your
comments and I guess one person who um
was listening earlier and he voiced his
um support for verion of copian so
Nakamura must be pretty pleased with
today's result yeah kind of like guess
it so to speak one uh point I just have
to make about this game between teor
garv and Alejandro Ramirez when you look
at this position um and you realize well
it's got to be it's so wild because the
two connected pass ponds by white versus
what's happening on the queen side I
mean it's really almost criminal uh I I
will have to
shall we say slap
Alejandro uh how can you play today C
beating up what what are these Grand
Masters thinking how can you play you're
talking like Maurice now how can you
play a move like King takes C6 that is
really astonishingly bad I mean it it
really is astonishingly bad first of all
you have a double Pawns in the position
so obviously you recapture with the pawn
one of the nice things actually about
this k King is after you get in the move
like B2 this King might end up going to
B3 and going after this Pawn the
knight's going to come back anyway so
sorry as but we just saw him look at his
position you saw the way he just
scratched his his hair he looked very
frustrated at that moment I think he's
realizing what you said uh in that
position that he did something wrong
here right well I mean he played King
takes C6 gaining a Tempo if he had
recaptured with his pawns first of of
all he tremendously improves his pawns
his King is fine but white is actually
going to have to play the move Knight E5
anyway so now you've uncovered the pawn
and in the line that mauie showed where
the pawn moved to C5 and setting up for
this Knight takes D3 C4 types of ideas I
mean black could just be winning the
game I appreciate the fact
thatter I mean it's really bad it's like
Halloween you know
I we got we got moreal results while uh
y digests I'm trying to recover over
here I mean this is painful well Nar
kamsky was a draw so L played King vers
King excellent we finally agreed and um
and we also have a big win by our
youngest competitor in the whole
tournament um ashria iswaran has
defeated aruk so wonderful forri did
give up and yeah very very exciting
debut by asria who now has is um three
and a half points so she's back to an
even score because remember the women
have played seven rounds whereas the men
have played eight that's right so and
they actually get another free day
because their their tournament is two
rounds shorter so on Sunday it'll be
just the US Championship a 12 player
field versus a 10 player field for the
women yes clear and here she is a swaron
she is with Maurice
Ashley well one of the future great
players in US chess uh particularly on
the women's side but certainly looking
to dominate even on the men's side as
well I'm sure ashri Ron after a victory
ashria how are you feeling I'm feeling
really happy and looking forward to my
last two games now it was a great start
for you you were just like blitzing out
in the with the field but then it became
difficult in the middle how did you keep
your composure when it was was getting
tricky to play I just continued to try
my best and whatever happens happens
that's what I thought so when you
started losing did you think you're
going to lose the rest of the games no
how come I believe in myself and thought
I could get more points like if I played
more carefully so why would you think
that I mean you're the lowest rated
player in the field uh there's a lot of
veterans here why why did you think you
you should have that kind of confidence
or why do you have that kind of
confidence well I as long as like I try
my best like if I play equally it should
be okay but I just had like an instinct
an instinct of feel an instinct of of
the strong let's go just to your game
for a second against uh Arena
zenyuk and what happened in this game
what what turned it around I think when
she did Bishop G4 in time trouble like
on the 40th move she pinned her Bishop
so I was up a piece after that right
that was a big moment was she in time
pressure for a long time in this
game uh when she reached like move 25 I
think right so 15 minutes 15 moves of
time pressure how do you handle the
opponent's time pressure you are moving
so quickly looks like you don't get into
time pressure you had a lot of time left
on the clock how do you keep your your
calmness when you see your opponent just
on the edge that way I just keep trying
to find the best moves and just play my
best you don't move you don't think
about like sometimes get tempted to move
quickly no not at all I know a lot of
people get tempted to move quickly where
did you learn that from no one just by
myself again Instinct uh your tell us
about your coach uh what how has he been
helping you in this tournament he just
helps me like tell us his name first and
and then tell us Dion B he helps me in
like opening and like we just practice
middle
positions and like end game positions
does he give you advice before the games
what does he say what are the kind of
things he he just says good luck and uh
good luck yeah you know he's not
supposed to say good luck or chess we
need good skill maybe or play well good
luck is one of those you know chess is
not supposed to be a luck game you could
tell him have fun have fun good luck and
have fun well it seems like you're
having a lot of fun at the tournament
and uh we hope you do well in the rest
of your games thank you ashria swon
doing quitting herself well here at her
first ladies championships guys the
self-confidence is great right oh God
yeah this I love that this is a great
debut and it's wonderful to see her
succeed and I'm I'm sure all those of
you who don't have stone for hearts
enjoy her interviews right exactly
exactly I I just want to point out well
we hopefully we get set up for another
interview um ireena crush's position
against the being a foer reminds me of
another position in this tournament um
now just in a pure aesthetic purpose
we've got take a look at foer um and
crash iname just a second I'll close
this I
me because we we we we have a number of
results and I said also that csky and
niski have draw in their game right and
tat whoa tat abrahami and Victoria also
made a draw that one we weren't quite
expecting were we um look at that fiser
versus Crush all of the all the white
pieces are in the dark squares and all
of the um black pieces are in the light
squares and Irena continued this trend
with the move age5 now look at a game
that we Haven Checkers yeah exactly now
look at a game that we haven't seen at
all today but um just the final position
um molner shankland okay I think that
was game
six uh oops sorry didn't get it this
reminds me a little bit of Beno so you
see that diamond Pond structure yes
remember uh Beno who's also won US chess
championships he's also a great problem
composer and uh he would actually make
problems based on the shapes of the
ponds so this would be like a whole Seri
on diamonds where all of the pieces
would be in a diamond shape and you
would have to find a maiden two or a
maiden three I know and he even did
letters he did like all the letters of
the alphabet yeah I know very very nice
and the ending to this game was uh the
players agreed draw here it's actually
remarkable that after what roughly 40ish
moves that you would end up with a
symmetrical position after 40 moves
quite remarkable much more pretty to
look at than to analyze right we didn't
really pay attention to this game at all
not too much happened and uh a draw was
the result but wait a second what
happened with nian abrahamian how did
that game end up in a draw um this is H
some major news here um I think uh
Maurice has the the scoop on that or
maybe at least the
theory well I explained before Jan and
this is one of the issues with the
championship there's a difference in
strength level between the top three and
the rest of the field and you find that
if one of the players has gets herself
in trouble like abrahamyan did in this
game she's thinking okay I'm a pawn down
but I'm much tougher than you are so
you're going to have to prove to me that
you can beat me and her opponent was not
up to the task she had to take a risk in
this game that she didn't want to take
she had to expand from this position
play a move for example here like Rook
to D5 let me just get this out she had
to take away this she almost felt like
she was the one who was under attack
here she has to play a move like Rook to
D5 to loosen her position just a bit so
that she can get her Pawn moving forward
possibly even chasing this queen away
with Queen B5 some chances here even
Queen D5 in that position was pretty
good there's no way yes if you and I had
this position with the white pieces that
we're just going to gift a draw to the
other player no way in the world I want
two pawns I'm going to be sitting here
we're going to be playing for quite some
time the other thing is that uh zenyuk
allowed herself to that is NE excuse me
allowed herself to get into time
pressure and that of course affects the
position as well but even so she's got
the 30 second
increment how could she allow the
repetition that she did in the actual
game this is what happened she just
started repeating moves after Queen to
D7 she played Rook to D3 Queen B7 and
now she played Rook F3 and after Queen
D7 she repeated this move and after
Queen B7 she did it again she was so
afraid of this
mating quote unquote mating attack on A8
that she allowed this position to be
repeated and maybe she was trying to
bank moves with the 30 second increment
at any rate she allowed the repetition
and did not win a game where she won a
pawn as early as move
10 really inexcusable on her part but
for tatv abrahamyan a fantastic result
because now she remains a point behind
Anna zatonski if if and when Anna wins
her game which means that if Arena Crush
wins that game then she will be in
Striking Distance of the leader again so
she's kept herself still in contention
here at the ladies championships guys
thanks Maurice and uh I think uh
everything you're saying about the top
three is really prean and in fact um in
the fiser Crush game that's still going
on I think that finally I will predict
that mikina is about to resign because
it looks like um zatonski has a A
variation that's going to reel things in
let's see that game as our tournament
leader Anna zatonski three pawns ahead
Bishops of opposite colors and at some
point she can just play um F2 and
maneuver her King to B1 and that should
be the end of the story precisely so and
then uh we still have a pawn I in fact I
don't know why she just didn't do that
last move she could have also done that
last move but maybe she has a different
way an easier an even easier way to win
like she's trying to play Bishop H3 or
something like here next move uh she
might just be trying to play Bishop H3
and then forcing the king king to play
uh King E1 and then it's even easier
just King C2 so we we expect a
resignation in this game shortly we've
been saying that for a while but this
time we really mean it we really really
really really mean it it's real but U
meanwhile in for your crush I mean I was
I was like I mean it seems like maybe I
is now playing for the win I mean look
at look at what's going on in this game
okay and I mean really it's like they're
playing a f minute game with increment
right with Queen still on the board and
both Kings looking Black's King
certainly very exposed and White's King
looking like it's going to become more
exposed
so H4 a double-edged move because it's
loosening the pawn on G4 but she's also
getting ready to play um possibly G3
check and uh open up lines against the
king in the G2 Pawn so sabinaa actually
already played a move here she played
Queen to E2 they're very even on time
here they both have a little over six
minutes but it just seems like this game
is going to be decided in time pressure
I how can you not make that prediction
right well exactly well it is horrifying
it's been just a day of Horrors uh uh
Arena playing for a win from a worse
position and
Sabina uh acting as if she has the worst
position and Sabina seizing the
defensive even though she's in a better
position although to be fair if she
really thought that she was going a
worse position she had opportunities
early in the game to simplifies so why
wouldn't she have taken them like so
many opportunities rookie seven or but
even like really clear ones or like the
queen G3 one it just seemed totally forc
she could just traded everything off the
board so she must have felt like she
should be playing for a win somehow um
and this game I mean just we're going to
keep watching it because I believe it'll
be decided by a wacky time scramble
we've got tat bamum with us and maybe
she'll give uh her thoughts on what's
going on there as well as her Escape
against
me yes she may be called Houdini herself
after surviving this game tatev
abrahamyan with me you you were
disgusted I could tell we could tell
looking at you on camera after uh this
this move E5 just got you in terrific
trouble you sat for a long time here
what what were your thoughts uh staring
at this
position uh I SP a lot of time before E5
too for some reason I was convinced that
E5 is the line obviously I mixed up my
opening and then here I realized that
Bishop G5 Knight to I'm just way too
behind in development so there's no way
I'm going to hang on to my Pawn so what
were you thinking now I mean we saw your
head in your hands you were so close I
mean you're you're you have still have
good chances to win the the championship
and to to lose a game like this you must
have been kicking yourself at the board
I mean obviously this is not what I
wanted to get out of the opening but I'm
just not I'm just hoping for a draw
obviously from a tournament point of
view I need a win but given the position
what else can I hope for indeed uh you
managed to fight and then we saw the the
final position if we could uh jump ahead
if you don't mind bringing us to to the
final position why did she why did she
repeat moves I mean she still has Rook
D5 or queen she could still fight she's
up two pawns after all in this position
I'm not sure maybe I mean I don't after
Bishop F2 I don't think I have much of
an attack I guess she just kept
miscalculating so she got paranoid I
don't know did she say anything after
game she said like she couldn't
calculate anything anymore I I thought
Queen B5 was here a good move after
Queen D7 but um I think she didn't even
see is there a is there a an issue with
the three of the the top three in the
Women's Championship being significantly
ahead of the others I mean obviously
they're good players as well but you
guys are clearly the top three players
in the tournament that that it's
difficult for the lower rated players to
to break through and sometimes even in
winning positions like this they don't
press on U well I think what Irene and
Anna especially Anna what they're really
good at is just kind of sitting and
letting their opponents like create
something or create mistakes so I think
this is something they're really good at
and this is something I've been working
on to trying not to press the position
just kind of sitting and letting the
position develop on your own and like
especially if you're playing high rated
players you kind of get answer like when
you're not doing anything you feel like
you're losing control of the position
you kind of start doing stuff and then
that's when they like they calculate
better they see better so it gives them
more chances so I think if you kind of s
like if you have a bad position just
kind of try to hold on and if your
opponent's going to win then they're
going to win like what else can you do
but let them give them the chance to
make a mistake indeed and we see that a
lot of mistakes uh have been made did
you see the the game at all do you have
a chance to look at Arena's position
this one it looked like she was in a lot
of trouble do you think she's going to
try to win this game now um I saw this
positioned right at the time control
when she went G4 and I thought maybe G4
was not a good decision to make right
before time control um here actually
you're right it turns out that was a
really bad move and could have lost her
in exchange on the spot uh but her
opponent missed it yeah but I mean
that's one thing that's kind of
surprising because when you're in time
trouble you don't want when you have few
moves to make a few little time you
don't want the position to change
drastically you kind of want things say
stay the same and then you get time and
you think about it so it's kind of
surprising she would make a move like
that um what about now you think she's
going to try to press on for the victory
here um not sure
how certainly a difficult position for
her to try to win given but she's she's
decided to push these pawns down the
board I mean her king is not that safe
either so I don't think because I can
always somehow bring my queen in right
like Queen D3 Queen C3 well with what
you know about Arena and her situation
it looks like Anna's going to win her
game she's going to take a big a big
lead in that case knowing Arena Crush do
you think she's going to try to win this
game and then fight Anna tomorrow or
just take this uh with no risk is she a
no risk player or a full race player um
I'm not sure
actually to be honest I have no idea I
think she'll try tomorrow I mean I I
think she'll play on this position for a
little while see what happens but I
don't think she's going to go crazy or
anything like that deed well what about
you you're now at um your the score you
have you have two games against low
rated opposition again how are you
feeling about your play in particular
and the chances in the
championship today's game was not
inspiring but I have tomorrow so I'm
more optimistic about my game and your
chances for the rest of the the
championship I mean it's hard to say
there's always someone who's going to be
poting a half ahead of me so I mean it's
totally out of my control indeed well we
wish you the best in the rest of your
games and good luck uh in how you play
thank you T abrahamyan after a miracle
save really uh here at the
championship looks like that kind of day
guys back to you and thank you tat and
Maurice and we do have an official
and an hsky has won her game so we
expect to hear from her and then I don't
know I think that Arena uh Arena I don't
know I'm going to make a prediction that
she wins this game just because you see
that Sabine is actually going lower on
the CL two and a half minutes now to
Arena 6 and there's just still so much
going on in the position two week Kings
uh you know there's potential blenders
like I almost blundered and Analysis I
was thinking Sabina just played King to
F2 I mean King to Gan F2 and at first I
was looking at like Queen D1 because now
you're hitting the bishop on D5 and Rook
F5 is no longer possible because of
Queen G4 check but here there's G3 which
looks like it just wins the game
instantly sure so there are some things
happening here and so you're thinking
arena is going to win this one well I
think she has obviously I don't think
it's 100% but I think she has a better
chance of winning than sabinaa um
regardless of the position I mean so
actually just play King to G1 and I
guess there's probably a similar idea
there there so instead of Queen D1 now
she's probably thinking about the fact
that now that her King's no longer in
the F aisle she can play the move F5
uncovering an attack on the G4 Pawn so
it's true that Arena's pawns could come
to haunt her but uh so maybe and the
problem again is that Irena can't play
Rook back to F5 because Pawn on G4 is
now hanging so maybe this move King G1
is a good move but um what about what
about Rook coming over to um E7 what's
going on over there uh let's see what
Maurice has to say all about all this I
I just think with very little time in
the clock this is going to get messy and
I don't know if a draw is going to
happen draw scha I don't think that's G
to happen either there's no way that
Arena Crush once to draw this position
you know you got to get greedy when
you're a GM you get greedy even if you
lose you want you feel like you know you
should have beaten me a long time ago
now I've turned the game around I'm not
looking for a draw anymore that's just
the mindset of an assassin and I think
that Arena crush is thinking I'm better
than you I'm supposed to win plus she's
just seen an a win so she's going to try
to make the most out of her chances it
may be disastrous for her if she's not
careful but I've actually watched her
play Blitz and she really is a pretty
good Blitz player uh moving really
quickly coming up with good moves uh
she's definitely going to challenge her
opponent and look for those lines that
create difficulties of course she
doesn't want to lose so she's going to
have to be careful I should point out a
result that it looks like it's going to
be a result guys in the gev Ramirez game
and it seems as if this game is going to
end in a draw after the move H4 B2 H5
King to E7 this Pawn steaming down the
board Rook F1 preventing the king from
getting any closer and Ramirez had to
hurry up on his high horse and get his
Knight to E3 and after Rook B1 play the
move D2 and now he has two point pawns
to get a queen white was able to play H7
and after D1 queens that one was removed
from the board and then h8 queen and a
new black queen on the board but it
looks as though it's going to be pretty
difficult for the black king to get out
of a series of checks here so we expect
the game to end in a sort of Perpetual
check and it seems as if the game has
indeed concluded in a draw I believe
that is the result let's just make sure
and it seems yes indeed a wild game
these players really entertained us here
but uh the the Lust For Blood was in the
air Y and somehow white just let the
game slip away it should have been his
for the taking and now he has to accept
that his chances of winning these
championships have pretty much Slipped
Away guys and now we have uh only one
game still being played uh foer crash uh
both with just just over two minutes on
their clock and basically playing on the
increment I I I said sabinaa had a big
time Advantage um that was four minutes
ago what do you know it's changed like
that now they're exactly equal a
dramatic a dramatic round with lots of
lots of bad play on both sides in both
events and uh this this game is also in
the balance it can go anyway rookie 7 is
there still an F5 move is that the idea
so F5 is still in the air there well
let's be clear I think White's better
okay that white has a better position
but I think it's going to be decided by
nerves and time trouble and it's not
about the position it's about the
confidence level of the players and
Sabina is simply not confident I mean
she's been seizing the defensive for the
better part of 20 moves or so although
at the same time if there there are some
lines that could end up being rather
simplifying like for instance that
particular one so there are some ways
that we can see a draw despite the fact
that it looks like it's going to be wild
like for instance if work to E7 um
F5 uh and isn't there going to be just a
massive trade here what about this
position yeah it would be a draw in this
case I think so there are still some
drawing lines even though um if the
position continues to stay rich I think
there will definitely be no draw arena
is getting down underneath one minute
we've seen her get down to two seconds
and 1 second and she's still thinking
she still hasn't made a move we see her
here in the webcam I mean it's Terri
terrible 45 seconds 44 still in the
realm of professionalism that she could
get 40 seconds don't you think but when
you're under I think that what you're
what's really disturbing you more is
that she started this move with 66
minutes and three times as much time as
her opponent and now she has half as
much exactly so that is just a major
difference um and she's just simply made
a king move she's moved her King to h8
with the idea that now F5 no longer
comes with this um this check right on
G4
um is this a good
move
no I I don't like that I don't like that
move at all of course not you know and
you know the thing is why would you put
your King on a dark Square when your
opponent has a dark Square Bishop
exactly it's a terrible Mo it's crazy
and the thing is that Arena i' I've
argued with her about the whole idea of
increments and you know I agree and
disagree and and everybody has their own
opinion which is this is America after
all so you're allowed to have that but
there something about having increments
that people like and I think Arena likes
is that she's able to get herself in
this kind of mess and maybe work her way
out of it and we see her time and time
again getting into the time pressure
knowing that once she makes a move she's
going to get those 30 seconds I make a
move I'm going to get those 30 seconds
that's not if if you're going to argue
for increments that's not why you should
use that's not how you should use
increments use them wisely don't just
think and think and pretty your time
away said I can always make a move how
can she allow herself to go down to two
seconds one second on the clock and then
you know make moves like King h8 it just
doesn't make any sense to use her time
this way this is just a clear sign of
poor time management and uh maybe she'll
survive it but it looks as though even
in this position here that she's going
to be in some difficulties in the
meantime fer is allowing herself now to
go under a minute so they're both under
a minute and using their time really
really
poorly so again as Yer said this game is
going to be decided by nerves um Saina
has made a move she's played Rook to
D2 okay um so Rook from D4 back to D2
opening up the line for the bishop
coming to D4 check um trying to show
that perhaps that move King h8 wasn't
the best now Irena um 34 seconds 33 we
are just going to stay with you on this
game because this one is just going to
be decided soon I mean uh 26 seconds for
arena now 24 um she's listening to your
advice she's not letting her get herself
get as low as before she's played Bishop
to E4 to um block that potential check
on I mean not blocking the check but
blocking the Disco on the queen on E6
okay so so if I was white and again I
don't think it's about good play or who
has a better position if I was white I
would play the move Bishop F2 and again
I would think that white is better I
really think it's going to come down to
nerve still uh the way I looking at the
position
is Black's King is weaker than White's
King and there's a D6 Pawn that's weaker
than any other white pawns if Arena were
to play Rook takes F4 Bishop takes
H4
then Sabina has just a very safe
position but it doesn't mean she's not
going to lose it it's just it's all
about the time trouble and now she's
under 25 seconds
um did she even realize that she's under
this much time pressure she has 19
seconds left and now she's about to make
a move and she's going to I think she's
going to make it well before she Flags
but man it's getting pretty close there
Queen to F2 instead was what she played
you were Queen F2 move right Queen F2
going after the pawn on H4 and why are
these decisions so difficult for the for
the ladies to make I mean there's a pawn
hanging on H4 there's a black king on
the dark SC want to there there could be
some potential tactics and I just in
their defense I mean now that they are
down to this little time they also don't
want to Blitz the moves out and uh miss
something she might be worried about
time Arena has left I mean the clock is
ticking down and suddenly she finds
herself in a terrifically bad situation
because the move Queen to H4 Queen takes
on H4 or queen just appearing on H4 is
going to start all kinds of echoing
tactics there's a square on d8 with
check your D6 Pawn's going to hang
there's d danger everywhere now and
she's going to have to move very quickly
and navigate all these dangers so she's
put herself in a very bad situation
maybe has stretched it a little bit too
much she's still fine she's still fine
but boy the time is ticking down and her
hand hovering there right now over her
piece she did make a move uh we've got a
couple moves in H3 was played now Queen
to H4 check on the board gaining a
little time Arena um still under 30
seconds Sabino with just under a minute
uh I mean I wouldn't even be surpris if
somebody Flags can we see the time can
we see the actual clocks yes on us test
Champs live you see the uh you see the
game with the clock times ah so it's 49
and I that's why I'm updating you guys
on it 43 seconds now after King to G8
for Sabina fer and uh 49 seconds uh
Arena playing the quick King to G8 wow
so I mean the pressure here is so
intense I wouldn't even be shocked if
somebody actually lost this game on time
time because they're
getting PA with Queen to d8
check it appears that that did happen
well our hand is actually still over the
piece we haven't se oh that's your
analysis and queen G5 check instead has
been played Oh I thought that was
actually the move that was your analysis
I was thinking Queen d8 check was the
best move so I I played it anticipation
uh what could be simpler than playing a
check in time trouble Queen G5 check was
played I like this move actually I this
this I think is sneaky right cuz you
have to you have to wonder what's going
on for at least a quick second here and
she's played Bishop to G6 uh In This
Moment attacking the bishop on
E3 so Bishop to G6 has been played and
The Bishop's under under threat so uh
she shouldn't play Queen d8 check Rook
f8 that would be a not a happy ending to
the game so kind of setting up a little
bit of a cheapo there I'm guess F2 but
Rook e 2 is probably a good move here
but but but what but what was Queen G5
why didn't she go Queen seconds left for
subo
foer oh my she's going to lose it I
think she's just going to blow it this
is weird because of because I have no
idea why but I think savine just is like
she's like her her nerves are too bad
yeah she's snake bitten here I think
it's just the the greatness of Arena
Crush or2 occurred on the board and now
issue is that uh if King takes G2 Queen
takes E3 although of course that's not
the end of the story because G6 is also
hanging but I mean has to be actually
calculated all that with this under this
pressure but her King was perfectly safe
a moment ago and she's allowed H3 and H3
takes G2 what is that that's crazy
that's just just it's Insanity it's
terrible it's the nerves the time
pressure n she's moving her King back
and forth as you said she just moved
King to G1 now she's freezing a little
bit she's got only 10 seconds left on
her clock and she actually just played
Rook to E2 Irena now sitting a little
bit more comfortably with over a minute
for the first time in several moves so
now she wants to play King takes G2
without allowing Queen takes
E3 I don't know what she's position
though guys white is still fine uh of
course she's allowed some dangers to
herself and the clock is not healthy but
uh but white is white is still okay
White's probably no longer winning uh I
mean that movie as isn't Queen G4
possible there Queen G4 with the threat
of Queen G2 maybe oh it's it's all
possible but you gota like you gota like
ireena The Grandmaster now that they
both have exactly the same amount of
time right I just yes I would say so for
sure rookie seven on the board Rook s is
on the board pinning the bishop on E3 oh
I'm sorry at one moment did what about
okay so F5 now is check so otherwise
that move would be pretty pretty decent
she played rookie s rookie s was played
and now being a again like really down
down to her increment arena is kind of
seeming to make a little bit of progress
on the clock she has almost a minute to
beinga just um 10 seconds doesn't even
seem to be fully aware well she I think
she is aware look how quickly she's
moving and banging her clock she just
played King takes G2 and uh Queen to F7
has been I mean King to F7 has been
played trying to give her King some more
security and also preparing her Bishop
to come into the game uh with Czech on
e4 quite possibly it's still still equal
just has to move her King off of the
light Square I would think and now over
um over a minute Advantage Now by Arena
and I think that's what's what's telling
here Arena trying to use those
increments to to time bank a little bit
and SAA much more tentative and not
playing any moves super quickly um and
she's she's been unable to get back
there uh although to be fair there's
only a 30 second difference now 40
seconds for Saina forger just over a
minute for Irena Crush she did move the
King off of the lights sare as Maurice
Ashley suggested and she played King to
F2 she played King F2 okay right so
technically completely even on material
mhm and both kings are weak I mean it's
not like it's not like either side has
any advantage in terms of King position
although it looks like white is not as
coordinated as black but how does black
actually penetrate in the position black
has some ideas maybe like Queen to E4 no
because you drop the G Pawn so Bishop F5
is
playable um looking to maybe play Queen
to E4 after
that but it's not winning for black and
that's probably an issue how do you keep
playing what do you do next should you
repeat moves uh what should you do and
she's played the move
D5 D5 in the position threat with a
threat she's got a threat now Rook to E1
is a possibility so that if D4 we can
play Bishop to D2 and kind of turn the
tables
perhaps Rook to E1 looks like a really
good idea actually uh probably should be
played Rook to E1 and
and put her piece on a dark Square will
she find it though and and she is not
finding it dropping it down to 15 12 10
10 seconds she's hovering her piece over
over her Queen instead and she played
Queen to
E5 giving back the pawn here giving up
PA
Pawn so she's just frightened that's
what's going on she's frightened
of something bad happening she's not
looking at no she's not looking at her
possibilities at all she's just reacting
to every every threat if Arena so much
as threatens a check she she's making an
attempt to to stop the check so this is
just
like like I think Arena's going to win
this one now do you think arena is just
going to win in the end game now no not
that I just think she's going to win the
position and she has traded queens has
Arena crushing for the first time she's
up remember at a point she was losing so
the grandm showing that uh Grand Masters
are Grand Masters for a reason and now
she is up a pawn but it doesn't look
like a winning position the hinia
thought that it was better to retain
Queens with the move Queen C6 and and
practically that looked good too but
here it looks as though another Bishop
of obos color straightforward rookie
Bishop ending and uh maybe much closer
to a draw for fer although I I have my
doubt she's going to save herself in
this game I think yeah her plan now is
that she has this possibility of Rook to
E5 coming into the position and it's
very difficult for uh Irena to stop that
so you know trading further down into a
bishop of opposite color endgame even
without Rooks well I I'm pretty sure
that uh because after Rook F5 check
isn't there um there's King G3 right and
then Rook E5 is coming right I was
looking at this kind of an ending I I
mean it it's drawn right you're pawned
down in the Bishops of opposite color
ending um you're doing your best it's a
draw I I'm I'm with Maurice a very
surprise especially because um poer was
showing showing how frighten she was of
every black possibility Arena should
have just kept queens and going into
this ending is a great relief for Sabina
because she's just seeing ghosts
everywhere uh under and behind every
single move at the same time though it's
not that easy for Irena either playing
down almost to the increment almost to
zero it's also a relief to get an end
game where you only have two results so
I think that might have played into her
kind of in you know you're the GM you're
a stronger player if you're going to
start being scared that's that's not a
quality no I'm sorry that's not how
that's not how we do I mean sorry you're
you're supposed to say okay we're going
to test each other right now and see who
makes the mistake especially if you know
that your position's fine well really
what was going on is like Arena's really
uh chasing Victory chasing Victory
chasing Victory so she's now in this
situation where her opponents begging
her please go into an endgame of Pawn up
but give me Bishop's opposite color I'd
say no look I've been chasing victory
for the last 20 moves I I'm going to not
put you in your comfort zone I'm going
to keep you in an uncomfortable State of
Affairs where you know you're terrified
of everything but anyway let's see what
has happened because
Arena seems to think she has chances in
this ending and I don't share her
conviction she's going for another
constellation of pieces here so instead
of The Rook on F5 and the bishop on H5
she's put the bishop on F5 and The Rook
on H5 all right how did she do that
power to her I wasn't even sure that was
possible uh so they got this position we
saw the move Bishop D4 The Rook is
transferred it over King G3 the bishop
came to F5 and this is the position we
have on the
board okay and now Rook E5 played on the
board uh obvious move Rook E5 uh just
setting up uh problems for black uh as
we see yeah now we're much closer to the
draw yeah this te actually closer
because now the the bishop couldn't move
and I think after Rook AG three Jack I
think did she play it by the way Rook H
play Rook H3 Rook e Rook H3 check and
King F4 seems King exactly and now
something like Bishop E4 I got to hold
on to the D D5 Pawn don't I otherwise
it's absolutely nothing right exactly so
then just make a draw with Rook G5 but
what what about ideas of instead of that
move what about Rook F3 check I'm just
wondering back up right here Rook F3
check is not possible and then rook and
then Bishop to E6
maybe and King F4 was played so we'll
get we'll get to see whether Irena is
trying to play Rook F3 check or just uh
Bishop E4 as uh yaser suggested so you
want you want to play Rook D5 after
Bishop B4 and just go for the activity
against the A7 I'm not sure what
position we're in I'm sorry just let me
Let me refresh the board for just a
second Rook E5 occurred and now um
Sabina has played after Rook H3 check
King to F4 trying to stay active and and
get a draw in this game and now Maurice
is asking about the
variation F3 check here King G5 Bock
Bishop to E6 I suppose well um I don't
know Rook I'll just pick a move Rook F2
idea perhaps of uh rookie two idea of
Rook F2 and Rook F5 check just to stay
tricky
maybe and uh Irena did get down to 10
second six seconds it looks like and she
played uh Rook to F3 check King G5 on
the board okay so we we've get we're
guessing the players moves thus far so
we have this position this is our
current position uh black to play we're
expecting Bishop E6 trying to keep all
the pieces on the board correct and
still massive massive time pressure even
in this more simplified position uh
Arena seems to be getting under 10
seconds for every move uh foer's banked
a little bit and has over a minute now I
see and she did Play Bishop to E6 and
how about the move Rook E3 by the way
rookie 3 is the strongest move here
according to the computer the way AR was
not suggested as best uh this is the
line my instincts went for but Houdini
didn't like this way it wanted to play
Bishop on e4 as well so now we're in a
position where it looks like it's
drawing but this is the most human
continuation of all I mean this clearly
the typical way you would play as a as a
human and I think Rook F1 now and just
keep the game going okay so Bishop E4
was the suggestion of the computer
Bishop game is a clean draw by the way
still he doesn't think any advantage
it's just can you make her suffer that's
really what we're down to so we're
looking at rookie 3 and she traded she
traded Rooks
remarkable I would have never guessed
her to do that because now it just seems
like uh how are you going to find a way
to win for black now exactly just she's
going to post the bishop up up on D4 and
how can the king even really infiltrate
there's nothing to discuss not but you
know what the problem was Rook 3 was in
the position if if you don't if you try
to avoid trades Rook C3 was in the
position and then like right here yes if
Rook F1 for example like I threw out
Rook C3 and suddenly checks are coming
and and uh it's White's turn to take
over the initiative so it looks like she
saw that and then she traded and now the
game just looks like a draw yes uh very
much so so I mean again Sabina was
exceptionally exceptionally happy see
the Queens come up
really really happy to see the Rooks
come off the board and now she's Ultra
confident she's got the draw in her
pocket because actually it's a very
simple Fortress even if we were to
imagine that Arena got everything she
could possibly want and for example a
position like
this we gave Arena the opport
opportunity even put the king to B3 all
white does is just shuttle her Bishop
between E5 and D4 and say nothing draw
right and and they are continuing to
play but now we know that the players
are also going to be able to bank plenty
of time yes and so even though we were
right that a lot of things changed in
time pressure because of the trades it
did end up becoming by the way you just
saw that look on Arena's face it was a
quick tick of disgust in her face and
now she's put her head in her hands and
she's knowing now she's it's clear to
her that this is nothing she can do to
win although her opponent just played
what may it's a big deal what what's
what's going on she just backed her
Bishop away but there's there's no way
to to do anything about it yes it's she
just dropped the bishop back's no way to
get sorry I saw a bishop coming back I
thought the bishop was on
E5 to C3 went to G3 or something a lot
what no no no okay so she she put her
King on F6 interestingly enough and her
last move was Bishop F2 just dropping
her Bishop back and saying okay I've got
a different kind of Fortress but it's
good enough and Bishop A6 was played now
but there look at Arena now she it's
pretty clear you can tell she knows that
this is a draw she should not have
traded Queens a very bad professional
decision in that moment and uh she's
well aware that she has no plan that
could possibly make any progress here
exactly well look at what happened when
she get down to 10 seconds both in the
first time control there was that
mistake with G4 and then in the second
time control as well so it was all about
that playing on the increment and you
know it even if you're good better in
time pressure than your opponent it's
still resulting in blonders
exactly so should this game end in the
draw it would mean that Anna zatonski
our tournament leader going into the
round will have increased her lead to a
full point that's right she'll be a full
point ahead of Arena crush and playing
Arena Crush tomorrow before The Showdown
definitely it'll be a very big day so
everybody at at home tomorrow it's a
weekend no excuse you gotta got to be
here to tune in and we actually have
Anna Tony getting set up right now if
you happen to have any last minute
questions you know use our hashtag us
chest Champs well it is extraordinary
that these two ladies Anna and Arena
have been such a dominant force in the
women's game for the last 10 years just
sharing the titles amongst themselves
and once again it appears that that's
going to be the case in the 2014 US
championships it sure looks that way and
uh here she is Anna
satony now firmly leading the US Women's
test Championship after a victory
against Alyssa mikina
today yes we're with International
Master Anna zatonski Anna welcome to the
show yeah thank you Anna before the show
before the round I saw you and I asked
you how you were doing at the hotel we
just bumped into each other in the
elevator and you said you were you were
you were good doing good and you also
said that you felt rested and prepared
yes it's true now why did you have that
that Holy Trinity if you will that's a
great feeling to have as a chess player
um I don't know just I think I'm
professional playing chess for many
years so I'm just already familiar with
right attitude but it's not always
working but I know what I should do and
what is to be in good shape and to play
well what did you do on the rest day in
the rest day I Was preparing and I had
uh breakfast long breakfast eating
resting I visited this music show in
Hall of
Fame so just basic stuff just basic
stuff I didn't go shopping so sure your
husband was happy about that uh you
prepared was the word did you know she
was going to play into this line in the
French uh I wish I would I would know
this otherwise I would uh prepare more
deeply this line and of course uh I
considered this possibility and I missed
up variation
and how so and very soon instead of R
Rook I should play Something Different
yeah oh indeed actually like I said I I
wasn't sure that she will repeat this
variation because she had this Gambit in
first round against Sabina fer and I in
the second round I think it was actually
she had the white pieces oh yes right
right in second round yes exactly and I
wasn't quite sure that she will repeat
this variation because obviously I'm I'm
expecting this line mhm yes and but also
consider many other variations from here
like many gambits because I think she's
she's playing good attack and chess and
I consider it many other gambits for her
indeed uh were you surprised you said
you were surprised she played this way
but then pretty soon afterwards you had
control of a position and then all of a
sudden it looked like you lost a little
bit of control your queen was shifting
back and forth and ended up on A3 did
you feel like maybe you had lost control
of the game at some point yes uh I I had
feeling that I messed up variations or I
just forgot something and this still
unclear I wish I would like I said I I
would to dig deeply on this position at
home yeah with computer with and then I
spent like half an hour and I think que
H4 is a good idea because later G3 was
very very helpful for me so I I put her
in trou on this diagonal and I think it
was also important uh to block third
rank from The Rook because in some lines
it was attack and Rook could either go
through E3 to G3 in some variation and
yeah actually yaser mentioned that uh
the idea of the Rover Rook up and over
was lost in the position after she
played G3 so that was good for you yes
yes so it's uh this was my idea to play
Queen H4 and then Queen A4 instead of
playing Queen A4 right away I see so you
end up winning this bishop opposite
color ending uh this dominant position
for you your opponent your main rival
excuse me Arena crush is looking more
and more like she's going to draw that's
going to put you a point ahead of her uh
in the championship how do you handle
your next round against her you guys
have battled so many key games over so
many years it's it's it's just it's it's
uh we go back to Martina Chris ever to
see this kind of the classic rivalry uh
in tennis um what what do you do to to
be the Victor this time she's gotten you
in the last uh year uh okay I will
probably try the B not nothing your I
will I will not tell you nothing your
but I will try to get a good rest a good
opening preparation fresh head and
what's what what else maybe I'll will
try to get more motivated I don't know
more motivated you're a point ahead in
the US Women's Championship with two
rounds to go against your main rival how
much more motivated do you need to be uh
I don't know sometimes when you're
basically draw is in my favor but it's
it's extremely difficult to do it so
maybe I shouldn't play for draw so just
try to find balance because I know it's
very difficult when uh tiebreak playing
uh World Championship it's men and W men
and women when you're leading it's very
difficult to make a draw and this is
common mistake to play for draw so I
will try to play my best chess and no
way will just trying to hold draw oh
that's great to hear because we uh we
don't think she's going to play for a
draw either yes yes I know I know but
this is this is a big mistake just to
play for draw because it's usually it's
doesn't help chess avoid avoiding sharp
lines and uh maybe if I will have a
chance to go in equal end game or to
sacrifice a bishop maybe I will
to make it to make the position even yes
yes something like that but like in
general I will not I will not exchange
Queens on purpose if I have some other
lines so we will see and in her mind you
do expect her to come straight after you
don't you no I don't expect I think like
some opening preparation because uh like
I said I didn't play like Ser just over
here and uh she she did like probably
she's a little bit more up to dat so I I
think she will try to do something in
open it's maybe surprise me with some
lines which she didn't play uh do you
feel confident going into tomorrow's
game okay right now I feel absolutely
comfortable
after after winning my game right
yes I think I'm
comfortable but confident was my
question confident confidence yes
playing against uh your main rival yes I
played many games against H
so I don't know what what what else you
she will
do well thanks very much for joining us
and we wish you the best in the next
rounds thanks for international Master
Anna zatonski playing like Grandmaster
Anna zatonski right now one more Big
Time game to play tomorrow against her
main rival Arena Crush who looks like
she's not going to win her game back to
you guys and she didn't in fact that
game has uh been drawn and in fact you
can see them signing score sheets here
in our webcam so that gives us two very
exciting situations at both the Women's
Championship and the championship Irina
Crush um a point behind her main rival
Anna Zony they're going to play tomorrow
don't miss it a barn burner to be sure
and it also gives us some real
excitement in the championship vuan aobi
and also a point ahead of his main rival
gotsky and they're going to play on
Sunday so a weekend of excitement here
at the US Chess Championship this was a
fabulous day I'm I'm Jennifer shahadi
and we've got one final thought for
Maurice Ashley before we close today but
make sure that you join us tomorrow
indeed Jen it's incredible watching this
round today you know the players had a
rest day we expected them to use it to
get fresh to play Pure Chess today and
yet we saw mistakes Galore of course we
like mistakes yeah but also you feel
like wait a minute this is the US
Championship you shouldn't be erroring
like this uh at this stage of the
competition but who cares as far as
verua niobian is concerned thanks
I'll take the point as far as Anna
zatonsk is concerned thanks I'll take
the Point Arena Crush has got to be
bitterly disappointed and of course on
godak kamsky side drawing with black is
getting him nowhere so tomorrow it's all
to play for it should be really exciting
one of the more exciting rounds of the
championship so
far that's right and uh I think yaser
wasn't happy about the mistakes I saw
lots of looks of Despair he loves CH so
much that it physically makes
when somebody blunders and know I think
it's like oh it's exciting lots of cool
stuff are going and for you it's like
your blood is curling dispair tomorrow
exciting chest but fewer blunders I hope
so that's my prediction I hope so but
really when the two top players in the
field Anna and Arena sit down to play um
I just know once again that it's about
confidence it's it's going to be
dramatic whatever else happens it's
going to be dramatic and I'm looking
forward to uh the game of the
tournament see you tomorrow at 1:00
Central 2:00 Eastern time here at the US
chess championships in the capital chess
in America St Louis you don't want to
miss tomorrow we' got cross and zon
playing for what's going to be the US
Women's chess championships P
game
[Music]